although they go to William beauty
just not kidding it's an orphan baby is
not kidding it's kind of is that okay
fry yeah I'll be speak English that's
what I'm saying oh yeah because we can
actually speak the Norwegian same
Norwich oh we all speak English so it's
easier otherwise yeah actually you're
quite you're quite tall to be a jockey
aren't you I would be I mean jockeys
come in all shapes and sizes you know
but some are taller than others but I
would be a little bit taller than the
new classical jockey build and obviously
which then makes you know that the
weights how do you how do you keep your
weight it's a lot of discipline I mean
my life is my whole life is a routine
and and it's very disciplined I mean
it's um you know I could tell you now
exactly what I weigh how much just but I
would now be 55 56 kilos probably 55 and
a half you know I mean and it's just the
way you you because you're you you're
with your body every day you're always
on the scales and it becomes it's you
it's your job it's it becomes a bit of
an obsession but at the same time it's
very important to have a healthy
lifestyle with it so I always eat very
healthily exercise a lot you know
exercise on top of riding horses as well
so I'm it's a very active lifestyle but
but if if you're if we're gonna I mean
right the next day and you see oh
I'm two killers too much if it's a day
before you're in trouble yeah I mean he
knows before I mean yeah I mean 2 kilos
is a lot because you know you got to
remember we we haven't really got 2
kilos to lose you know that would be you
know if I'm like if I go on holiday for
four or five days if I have a break four
or five days I would put on two or three
kilos but that would be just eating two
meals a day and and just production
really does it happen that you really
start yourself
you have to sometimes when you have to
make an a low weight for an exceptional
purpose it's sort of like the Academy
Awards you know think the thing is it's
it's it's very important to to be level
with with your with your body in your
weight and you know the top and bottom
of it is that jockeys are are under a
natural weight most of the time tell me
were you aware that there are that golde
home is a very common name for horses
actually actually I go there did you
know no I only knew when you were coming
and then we looked up certain things and
then the mention to that so I look it up
today and I saw it my god there are
goldie Hawn's not just goldie I mean I
had a giraffe named after me once and
that was Goldie not Goldie Hawn but
horses and then I looked up a Goldie
Hawn and it was just didn't win One race
it does nothing happened and so yeah so
why would they name it Goldie Hawn
you're very famous foreign Beatty the
only is that there's no Fredrik skavlan
I'll put a word in
and I love them I feed them I kiss them
we have them on our ranch you know and
all of it when I fell in love with Curt
for the first time and he's a rodeo guy
I mean he can name any horse I mean it's
unbelievable
western style right and so he said to me
do I want to get you a horse and I went
oh really
and of course when we were in love first
we'd do anything and I ended up doing
dressage and some weird plays scared to
death doing a thing on the back of the
horse oh and all of it you don't think
of the back of those yeah basically and
after that I realized that I could never
do I was scared to death my heart was
pounding one time I was going up for a
birthday party and I literally the horse
too went like this yeah I knew it was
gonna run away with me I just knew it
and we were climbing the mountains in
Aspen Colorado
so I instead of the horse throwing me I
threw myself off the horse yeah yeah I
mean it's
listen it's um it's part and parcel of
the of the job and it's a it's you know
every job and support has a downside and
today today or yeah I mean you started
out very early
you were quite obsessed and today one of
the top jockeys in the world if we have
a typical race weekend how could that
look for you they could be so varied I
mean obviously Newmarket racecourse is
basically a three minute drive for me so
we could be there Saturday Sunday which
is a pretty normal weekend say seven
rides on the Saturday seven rides on
Sunday 14 rides and all hopefully get a
few winners or I mean you can get like
an extreme weekend where you could be in
Chicago on the Saturday and Deauville in
northern France on Sunday how do you
travel playing obviously when required
yeah sorry I know you mean when required
of course we have to resort to to
private jets because the schedule
doesn't just get yes it's a fact that
jock is a fluidly with private jets from
their owners a lot of the times do and
it depends on Jones because that's an
expensive game you know yeah flying
around private jets so and you know but
a very lucky that my owner Sheikh
Mohammed is uh he's he's very generous
he likes it and we have a passion for
horses and you can afford them then you
want to get the best and he did so I
have a question when you get on that
horse
how do you know it's a good one
obviously you but the first thing you
look at is the horse's pedigree and its
mother and father and you get a you
would always get a fair indication do
you talk to the horse
no not consciously anyway but you know
you get a why not I mean they like what
you say to a horse what do you say to
her giddyup yeah people talk to him
never
the problem is he always becomes a
one-way conversation cuz the horse never
talks back I mean you get a feel for a
horse like I can there's so many times I
ride a horse I've never seen before
never mind ridden before and I can see
the horse straight away and I think you
know oh I'm in trouble here too crazy
one or it's oh this is a good one yeah
thank God you know I can is this will
win and ninety percent of the time
that's the case you can get a feel close
just just looking at it because you can
tell it's body language and you can tell
by its shot by the horse shown its body
language you can you can tell what it's
thinking and then obviously when you
wear your when you're on the horse you
know you you have to become window horse
the eyes
can you tell by the eyes of a horse hmm
always look a horse in the eye before
you get on it why is that
well it's just like it's a bit like
talking to a horse
you know they cuz then the horse will
see you looking at ISA in his eye
yeah and it will actually look at you
and then the horse you will get the
horse attention so which I do prefer
well you always get linked up on a horse
on the left side so it's always the left
eye tell me you you you're now you're
working for for this this Sheikh of
Dubai previously you've been riding
horses for the Queen for for Alex
Ferguson the football manager for Andrew
Lloyd Webber oddly yeah but now you've
got this deal in Dubai and it's it's its
verge talked about the old because it's
so good tell me about it yeah I mean
it's um it's it's the best job in in the
world of horse racing it's the biggest
table the biggest owner and probably the
most one of the most passionate owners
and you know I was always very proud
when I got when I got the job last year
and and it's gone very well so far it
was a big step in my life of course you
know and a lot a lot has been written
about it and said about it but um you
know it's been a very successful move
for me yeah and also of course the
salary but also the prize money because
when you win you can you can win up to
how much is it for the 50 million
chromia or something like that
well it depends what race you win of
course yeah I mean the Dubai World Cup
which I won in late march this year I
mean that's the world's richest horse
race and I think that's that's worth
nearly 4 million pounds to the winner it
was my first time yeah
it's your money but not all your money I
saw how much do you you know of course
we get temperature jockeys get 10% and
that's pretty much worldwide in in every
country unless you have you know you get
some jockeys make a private agreement
you know for multiple sentences till you
get
if I ride a horse you won't get any
money if you ride going on
now I have a question actually because
I'm still thinking about the horse if
they have quite a good life the elite
horses the best horses yeah of course
because you know they have did they have
a very active lifestyle did they train a
lot you know they have horse paws
swimming pools Salaria solarium you know
so the horse will go for a swim in the
morning and then they were going under
the solarium just to keep it warm it's
not that different all day I think the
movie star it sounds like a movie star
life well that is a fantasy yeah well
unfortunately but we can live it it's
all in our brain yeah imagine it and it
will be but it but it is it's a good
life take care of horses
yeah but you know they aren't alive
today well it I mean sure is a
performance it depends I mean
performance on average probably you know
they start the curators as two-year-olds
some of them not all of them it all
depends on the individual but on average
probably four they compete to the four
on average four or five and and what
happens afterwards
what they become either broodmares or
stallions so they will they will breed
but after that again when they die after
they die yeah they've got the horse
heaven
please welcome Jeffrey Archer